is that what you did when you were a kid  did you like did you look up at the sky  and just go i need to know  yeah i mean that that's how i got into  science it was astronomy just like you  just looking up at the night sky  something captured my imagination  and  i want to know more about it that's the  wonderful thing about astronomy as you  say is the more you learn about those  points of light in the sky the more  wonderful they become and in the morning  at the moment the planets are up kind of  early morning then jupiter for example  you know if you look at that  just through a pair of binoculars or a  small telescope you see the moons  and then you realize that one of those  moons europa  has an ocean below its surface which has  got more water than all the oceans of  the earth combined was the size of  europa similar to earth it's smaller  it's kind of almost a small planet sized  so it's smaller than the earth but it's  just water beneath the surface